[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi.
And welcome to episode number
89 of the weekly Google Cloud
Platform podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I am doing very
well, having a very good day.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty good.
Very, very happy with
the amazing episode
we have today about video games.
So you're going to
be excited, too.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And it's
about video games but also
open source at the same
time, so even better.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
and Kubernetes so it's
like all my favorite things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
We're going to be talking with
true gentlemen Alim Jaffer
and Mo Firouz, both
from Heroic Labs,
and they're going to be telling
us a little bit about what they
do and how you can use it
on Google Cloud Platform,
if so you wish.
And then after that,
we'll have a question
of the week, which
actually comes
from one of our coworkers.
He came to my desk
yesterday asking.
He was like, hey,
how do you do this?
And I was like, I do not know.
So we figured out and
we have an answer.
And it's about how to access
Cloud SQL instances from Cloud
Functions-- fancy.
My question was like,
why do you do this?
Cloud Functions is super
hipster and Cloud SQL is not.
So why?
MARK MANDEL: Because by
joining these things together,
magic things happen.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The
hipster team, yeah.
But that will be at the end.
Before that, we have our
cool things of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And this week we are
returned once again
with the CRE team, Customer
Reliability Engineering team.
If you haven't listen to
those podcast episodes,
you definitely should.
They're fantastic.
They are talking
about dark launches
and what it does for me.
So basically, if you are,
say, reimplementing a service
or adding new functionality
into a service that
could potentially
break old things,
you can run it in
the background,
and they talk about
how you can proxy
the traffic between the old
service and the new service.
That new service-- the
customer never sees it.
The end user never
sees it, and then
you diff the data between
and see what's changed
and whether it's
actually doing what
it's supposed to be doing
with real information.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I actually did this in
my previous company.
Before joining Google, I was
working in a company, Amadeus,
and we migrated out of an
IBM mainframe called TPF.
And we rebuilt the whole thing
on there like on Linux and with
C++ to make sure that these
actually were the best way was
doing this.
You have a proxy, you get all
of the traffic from production,
you send that to both
the old and new services,
and then every single time
you get the responses.
You compare them.
You always send the one that you
trust, which is the old system.
But every single time there's
a difference, you log it
and you find an issue.
And with that, by the time you
don't have any more issues,
it means that you're pretty
much ready to migrate.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I just didn't know.
It was called Dark Launch.
MARK MANDEL: I did
not know that, too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Sounds Star Wars-y.
I like it.
MARK MANDEL: I just want to
do it now because of that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The second
cool thing of the week
is about Dataproc, and the
newest version of Dataproc
has been released.
So it's Cloud Dataproc 1.2.
For those that like
to use Dataproc,
it's basically the easiest
way to start Spark and Hadoop
on Google Cloud Platform.
Those two softwares
have also been
updated to the latest version.
So we have 2.2.0
for Apache Spark
and 2.8.0 for Apache Hadoop.
So check it out.
It's going to be even
faster, and there's
a bunch of new, small features.
So if you're using Dataproc
with Apache Spark or Hadoop,
or whatever you are using
from Dataproc, check it out.
There is a blog post that we
will link from the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
And it seems like
I'm on a theme today
where I'm talking about how
to safely deploy new things.
There's a blog post
actually back in June,
but I just noticed
it today and thought
it was really good, talking
about how you can do
Canary deployments using Istio.
So if you've ever been using,
say, Kubernetes and you thought
to yourself, how do I make
it so that 10% of my users
get this new thing and 90% get
the old thing and make sure
we do a slow roll
out, or maybe you only
want to determine just give
it to the internal users
that we have at our company so
they can dog food it before it
goes to the wider audience,
how you can do that, there's
a whole blog posterior
talking about how you
can take advantage of Istio,
another open source
project which
we have a previous
episode on as well
and how you can set up
a configuration for that
to make that happen.
It's actually cool.
I didn't know this was in
Istio, and now I'm super excited
and really want to play with it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
this is really cool.
This is actually
one of the things
that I really, really
like from App Engine.
App Engine allows you to do
this very easily and basically
based on the same thing.
Either you go with
percentage, or also you
can go with cookies so you
can target specific things.
This is even more powerful,
because you can even
apply regular expressions
on the values of the cookies
in order to decide what
version they're going to hit.
So that's really, really cool.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, why don't we go chat with
our pals over at Heroic Labs
and hear about what they're
doing all with Kubernetes
as well?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds
like a good idea.
Let's do that.
MARK MANDEL: I am
very happy today
to be joined by
two amazing people
from Heroic Labs, Alim
Jaffer and Mo Firouz.
How are you both doing today?
Alim?
ALIM JAFFER: Great.
And thanks very much
for having us, Mark.
Happy to be here.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
And, Mo, how are
you doing today?
MO FIROUZ: I'm very well.
Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Thank you so much,
the both of you,
for joining us to talk about
Heroic Labs and your experience
with the Google Cloud Platform.
But before we go into
that, why don't you tell us
a little bit about both of you?
Alim, why don't you go first?
ALIM JAFFER: Yeah, sure.
So I've been working in startups
for a couple of years now.
I'm based out of
Vancouver, Canada,
although I spend a fair bit of
time in San Francisco as well.
It's kind of my second home.
And I'm the VP of Product
here at Heroic Labs,
so my job here is to handle
the product, the waterfalls,
making sure we're moving
in the right directions
for the industry and generally
taking ownership over Nakama
itself.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
What about you, Mo?
MO FIROUZ: I'm one of the
co-founders of Heroic Labs.
We started this company round
two years ago, back in '15,
and I've been basically part
of the engineering team,
working on various products
and most recently on Nakama
[INAUDIBLE] server and the
integration with Google Cloud
Platform.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I guess that you should be
able to answer this question.
What is Heroic Labs?
What do they do?
MO FIROUZ: So we build
server infrastructure
for games and apps.
We provide an open source
server called Nakama.
That's on GitHub right now.
You can go and download it.
And what it does, it takes
care of all the infrastructure
needs, all the back-end
needs of a game or an app.
We have social APIs for games.
We have social APIs for chat,
for real time, multiplayer,
leaderboards, data storage, and
basically all sorts of building
blocks that games and apps
need to build to service
a live game or a live app.
ALIM JAFFER: So in short, our
primary product is Nakama.
It's an open source
distributed game server.
It's designed to power an entire
back-end for games and apps.
One of the big changes for us
was going the open source route
with Nakama, and we've had a
phenomenal reception to it.
And we've designed it
to be real time first.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I want to make
sure I understand correctly
what Nakama is.
So is it more like a framework?
Is it a library can be
used any language with it?
What does it look
like to develop
a game on top of Nakama?
ALIM JAFFER: Sure.
So it is your entire back-end,
from everything from your user
accounts to your data storage
to real-time multiplayer
to matchmaking.
We handle all of that.
So you could build, say,
a Clash Royale-style game
off of Nakama and not need
any third party services,
except for things like
analytics and anything
you wanted to do on
the data side there.
It's written in Google's
Go programming language,
and we have an embedded
scripting engine written, Lua,
so that you can add custom
scripts to it to customize
to suit more your
specific gameplay.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So does that mean that in order
to write a video game on top
of Nakama I have to use Go?
Or how does that work?
ALIM JAFFER: No, absolutely not.
So we have a first-class
client [INAUDIBLE]
for Unity, for Unreal Engine.
We're going to be
releasing a JavaScript
one in the next
few weeks, as we've
had a lot of demand for HTML5
games and also just apps
in general.
Because what you power for games
is really a superset for apps.
So anything that
can power a game
can certainly power
an app, and we
plan on expanding
this to kind of become
a base framework for games
and apps moving forward.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So now I really want to get into
the GCP side of things as well,
but what I really
want to know as well
is you said this is an open
source product that you provide
a source for.
Why is it open source?
Can you talk a little bit about
that decision making process
and why you ended up
building it that way?
ALIM JAFFER: Yeah, absolutely.
It was quite the contentious
issue internally for a while.
It was this strong debate
of do you go open source
and give away essentially
your secret sauce
or do you keep offering
a closed source solution
as so many people have?
One of the big pushes--
we were already
working towards it,
but when Parse announced their
shut down, it did a lot of harm
to the industry, both on
the games and apps side,
where people went,
oh, it turns out
we can't trust these things.
And there's already a large
not-invented-here syndrome
in the industry where people
want to build their own tecg.
So by going open
source, we wanted
to offer people both
the comfort of knowing
they can own the
technology, but also
the transparency behind it,
where they get to work with it,
do what they want with
it, fork it, modify,
have it suit their needs.
But the big thing was
to offer it to everyone
and go, look, it's not
going to disappear.
You can play a part of this and
we can build something bigger
moving forward.
It gives you the
ownership and control,
but simultaneously you get
something that's productized.
Because we're still working
on it every single day
and constantly
adding improvements
to it, along with the
community members who
are also contributing.
So it's a bit about growing
that community out and also
getting adoption out
there, and open source
is by far the best
route forward for that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
I was checking
right now the fact
that you actually have
all of your code at GitHub
under Heroic Labs.
And you even have
all the planning
on what you're working on.
ALIM JAFFER: Yeah, we're
real firm believers
in the open source philosophy
and that our roadmap needs
to be public, and
we want influence.
Basically, what we work on
next is based on our customers
and based on our community.
So when they say, oh,
hey, we want matchmaking,
we're starting to get
our games out there
and we need a better
way to matchmake,
that became our next priority.
And it's something
we're firm believers in,
that we don't build
games ourselves.
It's not our desire to.
But those who are building
games can help us work together
on here's what we need
and here's why we need it,
and we can make sure it
works at a scalable level.
MARK MANDEL: Now, I
know as well-- and, Mo,
maybe this is a
question for you--
I know on the website it
talks about CockroachDB,
but you build your platform
on top of other open source
products as well.
Can you talk a bit
about what those are
and why you made
those decisions?
MO FIROUZ: Yes, so
Cockroach being obviously
the biggest one, because that's
the only database that Nakama
needs to basically run.
Nakama's and our philosophy is--
if you think about
the cap theorem,
Nakama is the high
availability sort of stuff,
and Cockroach is the
consistency sort of stuff.
And we sort of give
the strong constistency
Cockroach will take
care of for us,
while we take care of being
highly available to the games
for various use cases.
We use various technologies
on top of Nakama
and to build Nakama on.
So I'd like to say Kubernetes,
for instance, is one of them.
Ansible is another one to drive
various parts of the deployment
process.
We use various Go
libraries, like Zap for log
in within Go or protocol
buffers, for instance.
We use Erlang and [? LXE ?]
in part of our platform,
and it's a combination of all
of those open source projects
that have sort of led to Nakama
being what it is right now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
I really like that you're
using so many languages.
Sounds very exciting.
Are you hiring?
MO FIROUZ: We are
always hiring, yes.
We can talk about that
after the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
Good.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Francesc,
don't leave me.
ALIM JAFFER: No free
lunch like Google, though.
I'm sorry.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Oh, yeah, then no.
So now that we've
talked a little bit
about all the open
source side of things,
you mentioned that you run
on Google Cloud Platform.
Could you tell us a little
bit how does it look like?
What products are
you using exactly?
MO FIROUZ: So I guess
the main crust of it
all is the Container Engine.
We use Container Engine
to power Kubernetes,
and obviously that uses
Compute Engine Instances.
And part of the
Container Engine is
used to contain the registry.
So we upload our images
into the Container Registry
and get Docker
and get Kubernetes
to run within the
Container Engine system.
And part of that comes while
logging and monitoring that.
We use Stackdriver for, pretty
much exclusively at this point,
the sort of cool, nice
storage for storing
various snapshots of
Cockroach's database
for restore and backup purposes.
And Log Balancer, both
sort of the L7 and L4
for load balances, for various
web socket and HTTP traffic.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds really cool.
How are you deploying your
Nakama onto GKE or Kubernetes?
Are you doing anything
special there,
or is it just
straight deployments?
Or can you talk about that?
MO FIROUZ: So remember
when I mentioned
that we run a few of
the path from code
in [? LXE ?] on Erlang?
So that niche of
the platform is what
drives how we run
our manage cloud
and how we deploy Nakama
into Google Cloud Platform.
So obviously we
have a build box.
That sort of builds the Nakama
images, the Docker images,
pushes them into
Container Registry.
Then we tell our
little app that we've
created that lives
within Container Engine
to talk to Kubernetes API to
create new server instances
and run [INAUDIBLE] version
of Nakama and Cockroach
we need to do, given the
configuration that we
have for Kubernetes within
the Kubernetes [INAUDIBLE]
effectively.
That little Erlang and [? LXE ?]
app that we've written--
we call it the manage
cloud servers--
the actual app runs
Kubernetes and actually talks
to the Kubernetes API, so we can
have a fully automated managed
cloud system.
MARK MANDEL: So does that mean
you wrote a client in Erlang
for Cloud and Kubernetes?
MO FIROUZ: Yes, we did.
Yes.
It wasn't fun, but yes, we did.
MARK MANDEL: Are you
going to open source it?
MO FIROUZ: I think it
needs a bit more cleanup
in some places,
but we've already
talked internally about open
sourcing part of the stock.
Because one of the
reasons we actually
went down to open source for
Nakama is what we've discovered
and what we really like about
the gaming space is that it's
sort of a tightly knit
industry, where everyone sort of
helps each other out.
And we want to give back
something to the game industry
and to the ecosystem.
And taking that sort
of idea, we want
to do the same thing
around certain libraries
or certain kinds, for instance--
in this case, Kubernetes'
Erlang client or
[? LXE ?] client
and give that back
to the community.
Because we appreciate
a lot and obviously
have taken a lot
from the committee,
and I think it's time for
us to give something back.
So we will do that
at some point, yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
At some point you
were talking about how
you are able to scale while
keeping strong consistency,
and I'm curious about
how you do that exactly.
You mentioned that
you're using CockroachDB.
Are those CockroachDB instances
running on top of Kubernetes
on GKE?
Do you run it separately?
How does that work?
MO FIROUZ: So Cockroach does
run on GKE and runs on GCP.
Cockroach is basically
distributed SQL engine that's
highly available, and they claim
that it survives disasters.
And what we've seen
so far is that it
does survive disasters-- not
that we've gone through many
of the cases so far yet.
What we can do
with CockroachDB is
we can cluster them together.
And we can start with,
say, one node of Cockroach.
We can use that.
It fills up.
We put two or three
or four of the nodes
together to get it
to form a cluster,
and when it's true in the
cluster, it will sort of load
balance the data on
the disk and copies
it across to various
nodes while it's
trying to join the cluster.
So we will always have
the high availability
and strongly consistent data.
It's not like, say, for
instance, Cassandra database
where your client needs to talk
with a specific set of nodes
in the cluster,
not all the nodes.
What happens in Cockroach is
you talk to one cluster node,
and it sort of
replicates the data
in the background transparently
for you across the other nodes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And so I know that CockroachDB
is based somehow on Spanner
and that one of the
powers of Spanner
is the fact that it
uses atomic clocks.
Could you talk a little bit
about is CockroachDB also
using the NTP service that
Google Cloud Platform provides?
How does it scale?
Do you know this,
or is it just magic?
MO FIROUZ: So it
is partly magic.
When you're running
CockroachDB, you
don't really get exposed
to that level of detail.
We certainly haven't told it
to use any sort of NTP service
within GCP.
It does come with
NTP services inside,
and it does seem to get
between different nodes.
It's sort of very
much hands-off.
You basically tell
it, so here is
where the Cockroach nodes lives
and go and connect to them.
And it sort of
figures out which node
came first, what is
sort of the master node
where the data exists,
although the term "master"
is a very specific term, a
sort of distributed system.
And how to
replicate-- it sort of
uses the [INAUDIBLE]
protocol to know
exactly where the notes are
and what data to replicate
and how to do it, rather.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I'm going to stop asking
you questions on databases.
It's really interesting.
Maybe we should
also have an episode
with CockroachDB or something.
CockroachDB people, if
you're listening to this,
please let us know if
you'd like to come.
But you say that you run all of
your service basically on GKE.
How do you deploy?
Are you using Container Builder?
Are you using
something homemade?
MARK MANDEL: Like Jenkins.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Spinnaker or Jenkins.
Or how does it work?
MO FIROUZ: We do use a slightly
modified version of Jenkins,
sort of as a build box.
And to drive the build box
and to drive the deployment,
we use Ansible.
And to drive Ansible, we
have we have a bot in a Slack
that we type commands on
to basically drive Ansible
and tell it commands
to do through the bot.
So if we are out in bars or in
pubs, as we have it in London,
we can just basically
connect to the Ansible bot
through the Slack app and just
tell it to redeploy something.
That's sort of the
methodology around it.
ALIM JAFFER: Yeah, I can't
remember what movie we went to.
Was it the Jason
Bourne movie and Andre
had to use the hero bot
and Slack for something?
MO FIROUZ: I think it
was one of those things,
because me and Chris
were quite into the movie
and we didn't really care
at that point what happened.
So Andre was the one on
call, so yes, Andre did that.
ALIM JAFFER: It's an
incredibly useful tool.
MARK MANDEL: And just for
clarification so that people
know how they're
using the tool, you're
using Ansible to push
changes like container images
and stuff like that
into Kubernetes itself,
or are you interacting
with, say, the cluster?
Or is it across the whole thing?
How is that working?
MO FIROUZ: No, the
pushing the image
are done by effectively
the build box that we have.
So we push whatever code that
we need to push into GitHub,
and then we have the hook that
runs a continuous integration
hook that builds the
image on the build box.
And then from
there, the image is
ready inside Container Registry.
And then we use Ansible
to say, OK, Google, sort
of the manage cloud servers,
go and grab this image
from the Container
Registry and tell
Kubernetes to deploy that
into this server for this data
space.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
I actually didn't know
Ansible had Kubernetes stuff.
That's actually super cool.
MO FIROUZ: No, Ansible
doesn't have Kubernetes.
Ansible talks with our
server, the manage cloud,
the Erlang node.
And then the Erlang node
drives Kubernetes and tells it,
so here's the app
that I have, here
is the namespace for
this particular person
or particular customer.
And the way we've designed
the Kubernetes namespace
is one namespace per
customer, effectively,
on that particular
Kubernetes clusters.
And we work with
our manage cloud,
saying, so this is the
customer's namespace
and go and deploy
this particular image,
say, Nakama 1.0, into
that person's namespace
and update it all and
then obviously update
the schema that needs to be
migrated and so on, so forth
from there.
MARK MANDEL: Got you.
So you basically use the APIs
that Kubernetes has given you
so that you can build
your own basically control
plane to control exactly what's
going on inside your cluster.
MO FIROUZ: Yes.
And that Erlang node, that
manage cloud server node,
also talks with the Google API
to set up various DNS records
and set up various
firewall rules.
Because there are certain
firewall rules, for instance,
for web socket
connections that you
can't set through the Kubernetes
ingress because they're just
not exposed there.
So we have to talk directly
with the Google Cloud Platform
within sort of L7 load
balances, the configuration,
to update and to say,
OK, set a timeout
of this particular
connection to X minutes,
for instance, so we can
have a live web circuit
connection going.
MARK MANDEL: So that was
actually interesting.
That was an interesting
sort of lesson
that you sort of seemed
to have learned about how
to manage GCP with Kubernetes.
Have there been any other
particularly good lessons
that you've learned
along the way
that possibly our
listeners might
want to learn from as well?
MO FIROUZ: From
the top of my mind,
I can't think of anything else.
There were a couple
of details that
weren't mentioned in
documentation that we found out
while we were implementing,
but there weren't many.
There were maybe a
couple, but this was maybe
four or five months ago.
So I can't recall exactly
what those details were.
But honestly, generally
speaking so far,
I'm really, really
happy with Kubernetes,
and I'm really happy with
Google Cloud Platform.
I can see that hands down.
It's been a breeze.
ALIM JAFFER: Yeah.
I mean, we've done deployments
on Azure, on AWS, GCP,
and I will say we've been
the happiest with GCP
both for network reliability and
also for the services offered.
It's kind of best suited
for us at the moment.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
since you mentioned
that you've done deployments
on a bunch of different clouds,
I wonder, why the Cloud?
What are the benefits for
you to be running those game
servers on the Cloud?
ALIM JAFFER: With
the Cloud itself,
we know how the Cloud
came to prominence 10,
15 years ago, where it
really started to grow
and allowed all these other
tech companies to come up.
You no longer need to spend
two grand to get a basic web
site running.
You could start building
some really cool tech.
And now that I feel the Cloud
is more or less mature, yes,
there are some outages;
yes, things happen.
But the general
usage of the Cloud--
it's incredibly immature.
And now as people are
getting content with it,
there seems to be a bit of
an arms race, in my opinion--
and, Mo, feel free to
jump in at any point--
between AWS, GCP,
Azure, and all of them
where something we call the
verticalization of the Cloud,
where now they're starting to
offer more bespoke services
for each vertical.
So for example, I
know games is growing,
and each Cloud is trying to
go after it more and more
because it's going
to continue to grow
and be larger and larger.
And as games go online more,
as there's more multiplayer,
as consumers expect
games to do more,
it's going to take
more resources to do,
and it also takes a lot
of complexity to build.
So we kind of view the
verticalization of the Cloud
as each cloud starting to offer
more bespoke services to build
on top of, but
that way they don't
have to start from scratch just
from the virtualization layer.
And that's kind of also where
we see Nakama ongoing where
it becomes a vertical upon
clouds to build forward.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Yeah, I just realized
one thing as you said it.
Where does that name
Nakama come from?
ALIM JAFFER: Oh, sure.
So it's a Japanese word.
So one of the guys, Chris,
one of the founders,
is huge into anime,
loves it to death.
We're trying to get him out
to Tokyo as soon as possible
so he can fulfill that dream.
And it means friends who are--
I believe it literally
translates as "friends
who are as close as family."
And so the whole
point of Nakama was
we believe games are
getting incredibly social,
and it's very much
a social server.
We have a social graph
built innately into it
so you can do queries, like,
show me friends of my friends
who are not yet my friends.
And Nakama seemed to
suit that pretty well.
It was going to be
the project name,
and then we just all fell
in love with it and said,
it's perfect for what we need.
So friends who are as close
as family, essentially.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Well, unfortunately,
we're running out of time
here-- just a little bit.
But before we wrap up, is
there anything either of you
want to be able to mention
or haven't managed to mention
or just want to plug
something in general, maybe
an event you're going
to be at or something
where people can find you?
What else is there that we
haven't managed to cover yet?
ALIM JAFFER: Sure.
A general plug I'd
like to make is--
we've gone over this
a couple of times
now with it being open
source, but we truly
would love the community
to come around this.
Whether you work in games,
whether you work in apps,
whether you're just curious
about back-end technologies,
we love the community
to get around it.
We have a Gitter channel.
All of our engineers are on it.
As you mentioned earlier, Mark,
we do have a public roadmap.
We'd really like people
to just get involved,
to open pool requests,
offer bug fixes,
or even just bug reports.
It's very important
to us as a team
and also as this technology
grows that people
get engaged with it.
So we are the stewards, but
we're not the only people
working on it.
We'll be at Pocket Gamer
Helsinki in September.
I believe it's in mid-September.
We'll be at Mobile Games
Forum in Seattle in October.
We have team members in
Austin, Texas, San Francisco,
Vancouver, London, England.
So if you're in any
of those places,
feel free to reach
out to us, and we'd
love to talk and just
get your feedback on it.
And if you want to get
involved, let us know,
and as mentioned earlier,
we are of course hiring.
If you're a distributed
systems engineer,
we want to hear from you.
MARK MANDEL: Mo, got
anything else to add?
MO FIROUZ: Yeah,
just one last thing,
which I think Alim missed out
is part all of this stuff--
I think next week
or maybe the week
after that, next
seven to eight days,
we're going to be releasing
the first stable version,
the 1.0 of Nakama.
So it's going to be out there.
MARK MANDEL: Congratulations.
MO FIROUZ: It's going to
be downloadable on GitHub,
and it's going to be stable.
And so we would like to
see more games and apps use
it going forward.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
ALIM JAFFER: Yeah, it's
a huge milestone for us,
so we're very excited.
We already have
games that are using
Nakama with millions of players,
but this is the official 1.0.
We're here to stay.
This is the stability marker,
and we're super excited
moving forward to have it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's awesome.
Well, congratulations,
and thanks, both Alim
and Mo, for taking the time
today to tell us a little bit
more about Nakama
but also especially
about how you built it
and all that cool stuff.
We learned a lot.
ALIM JAFFER: Yeah.
Thanks for having us, guys.
MO FIROUZ: Definitely.
Thanks for having us.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you very much.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thanks to Alim and Mo
from Heroic Labs for taking
the time today to tell us
a little bit more about all the
cool video games that you can
build on top of GKE quite easily
with the open source framework.
They're open source,
so check it out.
We'll have a link to their
GitHub repos on the show notes.
It's [INAUDIBLE]
worth having a look
and maybe even contributing.
It's open source, after all.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, definitely.
Super cool stuff
they're building.
And yeah, I'm going
to be excited to see
what they build on top of GKE.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I think it's time
to go with our
question of the week.
And the question of
the week came yesterday
from our coworkers,
because we're
on the same team, Gabe Wise.
He's a developer advocate that
just joined recently doing
internet of things at
Google Cloud Platform,
and something he was
doing is he's actually
logging the temperature.
He has a little sensor that
turns the current temperature
through--
I don't know exactly
what, but ends up
running Cloud Functions.
And then he wants to
store that piece of data
from Cloud Functions to a SQL
instance running on Cloud SQL.
Now, the problem is that in
order to access Cloud SQL,
there's a couple of
ways of doing this.
One of the ways is
by using App Engine
or by using the App
Engine service account.
Now, that does not work
with Cloud Functions,
because it's not App Engine.
It's a different environment.
The other option
is to say, well,
I'm going to allow the
connection from this IP.
MARK MANDEL: But Cloud
Functions is serverless.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
the whole point, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Is
there even an IP?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What
is the IP of no server?
Zero?
I don't know.
MARK MANDEL: Negative
one, I think.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah,
you cannot do that either.
So how do you do it?
And basically, the
solution is pretty simple.
You just use a proxy.
So what you're going
to do is there's
going to be a proxy
running with a specific IP
that you can then
hit from there.
And whenever you
connect to that proxy,
the proxy will connect
to the SQL instance.
And since that proxy
has a stable IP,
you can whitelist the
IP of the proxy instead.
So it's pretty simple.
It gives all the
security and stuff.
And the cool thing is that you
don't even need to write this
yourself, because
there's an open source
solution that is written here
at Google Cloud Platform.
It's called Cloud SQL Proxy.
So we'll have a link in the show
notes to both the repo, which
is worth checking out
and also documentation.
MARK MANDEL: And it's
also worth noting
that we did a
previous episode where
we talked about this as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
We have the episode 81 where
we talked with Francis Perry
and we talked about this.
So it's basically
the same solution,
but that time it
was about, well, I
have a manage instance group.
So you could have used
there an IP range,
because you could define that.
But with Cloud Functions
you cannot do that anymore.
So yeah, for Cloud Functions,
it's actually pretty easy.
Gabe did this yesterday
and it worked.
So check it out if that's
what you're trying to do.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
I like this as well because it
doesn't matter if you're using,
say, Cloud Functions.
You could use it from
manage instance groups.
You can use it for a
bunch of other things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You can even
use it from a [INAUDIBLE]
if you want to.
MARK MANDEL: If you want.
So Cloud Proxy gives
you a lot of flexibility
by giving you a lot of security
at the same time, too, which
is also really, really nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That's the important
part, because we tried.
It's like, maybe you can
whitelist 0.0.0.0/32.
MARK MANDEL: Which you can.
I mean, you shouldn't.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Actually,
it doesn't do it.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, really?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I feel good about it.
I was like, just open my
instance to the world--
not a good idea.
MARK MANDEL: It
wouldn't let you?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Oh,
that's very funny.
Well, that's good to know.
Excellent.
Wonderful.
Well, Francesc, before we finish
up today, where are you going?
What are you up to?
I think you're going on
holiday soon, aren't you?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
By the time this
episode comes out,
I will be packing
for my trip to Spain.
I'm going to be
there for two weeks.
And then in September, I'm
not completely sure yet,
but I might go to New York.
I might go to Sydney.
On October 17 and 18, I will
be at Velocity Conf in London,
and I will be teaching
performance profiling
workshop for Go and after
that probably go to Paris.
We'll figure that out later.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What about you?
MARK MANDEL: August and
September is going to be busy.
So I'll be speaking at Pax Dev.
I'll be at Pax West.
I'll be speaking at
GamerCon Las Vegas.
I will be speaking at
Austin Gaming Conference,
and then I'll be going to
one of my favorite places
in the world, Strange
Loop, just as an attendee
to hang out and chill.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Jealous.
That's going to be awesome.
MARK MANDEL: I'm so excited.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Well, thank you so much, Mark,
for taking the time today
to record a yet again
amazing podcast.
MARK MANDEL: And
thank you, Francesc,
for joining me once again.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And thank
you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: And we'll
see you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See
you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]